Vehicles battle Mayhem I'm of course
talking about the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by War
Thunder War Thunder is a free epic
multiplayer action game available on
Playstation Xbox PC and Mac battle it
out with a variety of ground forces
Aviation and Naval vessels from 10
different nations all with their own
unique features and controls spanning
from the beginning of the 20th century
all the way up to modern day their major
update La Royale was released for War
Thunder a whole French Fleet led by the
battleship Paris the legendary btr-80
the su-39 and more they even bumped up
the visuals because
what is battle without up-to-date
visuals and you can unlock additional
devices armor special equipment improve
the crew of a vehicle to increase its
stats and customize the visual aesthetic
make it yours so click the link in the
description to download War Thunder and
all new players and those who haven't
entered War Thunder for six months will
receive 100 000 silver Lions a week of
renting legendary German ground Vehicles
three premium Vehicles as a gift forever
XP boosters a week of premium account
and other bonuses get it all but get it
fast because a season of German gifts
will end soon wow sponsorship so epic my
hair and shirt changed for about a
minute that was crazy but hey Twisted
Metal so Twisted Metal it's a classic
PlayStation franchise I'm willing to bet
not everyone's played it I'm willing to
bet some people have played the wrong
entries because they're not all gold but
I'll make a strong bet about this
someone in the 90s played Twisted Metal
one or two in the 2000s played Twisted
Metal black the 2010s played Twisted
Metal on PS3 willing to bet they like
Twisted Metal because those are solid
it's such a video game concept of mad
news that I felt always lent itself to
seeing this on the big screen I'll take
a series but I just kind of thought that
movie with Jason Statham Death Race I
thought that was as Twisted Metals we
were ever going to see but now it's a 10
episode series or at least season one
you can stream on peacock I'm gonna be
completely honest with you when I was
watching it those first couple episodes
I was like
what the [__] is this it feels cheap the
humor feels Force it's not really
Landing for me at a point
I slipped into the weird bath that is
this madness I ended up having a good
time by the end I mean it might have
been a timing thing for the first couple
episodes I was like is this gonna get
good
it's either this or secret invasion
all right what's the next episode got
there is definitely a sense of Sweet
Tooth being a scene stealer for this
series I just felt they used Sweet Tooth
perfectly he is this psychotic wild card
in this psychotic world even the psychos
in The Psychotic world are like oh [__]
it's sweet tooth
there's just an uneasy feeling around
him there are a couple characters that
want to be his pal and you just know he
could still kill them for fun it's not a
safe place to be his friend what I
really liked about the execution of
Sweet Tooth is a wrestler named Samoa
Joe plays Sweet Tooth but Will Arnett
plays the voice of Sweet Tooth it was
actually really perfect as the voice of
Sweet Tooth but if you didn't know that
either production wise or hey that's
Will Arnett's voice that's also not Will
Arnett if you didn't know those were two
different people playing one role the
voice and the body you would swear the
person behind the mask is the one saying
the lines he did such a good job at
having his body language move with the
inflection of what's being said by Will
Arnett that it just looks like he's
saying it
it's not as common as you might think
we've all seen it where someone's behind
them asking you're like you're not
actually saying that though I thought
they crushed it in terms of having two
actors play one role and having it feel
natural so the stars of Twisted Metal
are Anthony Machias the character John
Doe from Twisted Metal and Stephanie
Beatrice is a character named quiet and
they team up together because he is
what's known as a Milkman in this
apocalyptic Wasteland this dystopian
future where cities are walled off but I
still need to get packages from one city
to the next and so someone named a
Milkman who has an expiration date
because they'll probably die has to take
packages and make deliveries between the
cities that's essentially what the show
is is we're taking packages from City to
City running into familiar Twisted Metal
characters we might get some Mayhem
along the way also Thomas Hayden Church
has agent Stone the cop and Twisted
Metal which actually he's a standout too
I guess I really like the Psychopaths of
Twisted Metal because I'm here for
Twisted Metal and that's essentially
what Twisted Metal is just a bunch of
nuts it does make sense to have a
twisted metal Main character be a decent
human being the audience can get behind
for the sake of you know tradition but
what can I say I like me the psychopath
you get a fair share of them here but I
gotta admit one of the things that just
bothered me it's actually a gripe I have
as time goes on just progressively more
and more I make this gripe when I talk
about a movie or a show it's just kind
of how entertainment's going
forced comedy so much of it you can tell
they want this to feel like Deadpool or
Zombieland as seen by the poster where
they're pretty much telling you hey this
is supposed to feel like those two other
properties but it when it's going down
when when there's clearly this comedic
moment that pauses for a laugh and I'm
just not laughing it feels like Dollar
Store Deadpool the world of Twisted
Metal in the games never felt as funny
to me as they felt dark it felt more
like Mad Max with moments of dark humor
absolutely but dark humor is different
than
this never happened to me before really
oh man I bet humor's totally bad just
when it stands out and doesn't really
land it's just awkward I don't like that
maybe that's why I like sweet tooth in
this series because Sweet Tooth does
have that dark humor that sadistic humor
that feels like it's pulled straight
from the Twisted Metal video game it's
like they put all their chips in that
basket not a bad basket to put your
chips in he's on
every cover but what this show has going
for it is a clear
heart and love for the property among
the people who are making it it does
feel like it comes from a place of love
and a labor of love you see that with
the character's Sweet Tooth you see that
with some of the Easter eggs in here
it's like that's kind of a cut
you did know that it's not like the
feeling I ever got with any of the
live-action Resident Evils where it's
like you've never you've never played a
Resident Evil game have you it's kind of
like what I was talking about in my
review from Meg to the trench when I was
talking about how something that's
cheesy yet fun is man that is skill to
pull that off or you accidentally fumble
[__] your way into it it happens that
way I don't know which one this is and
honestly they probably shouldn't ever
say and just be like yeah that's how we
do it
see you in season two it's something
that does throw back to the decade
Twisted Metal came out which is the 90s
it does feel like 90s cheese and to be
fair to all the last episode was all the
Twisted Metal car Mayhem I wanted in the
show in the first place if that
episode's any indication as to what
we're getting in season two totally down
in fact the second half of this season
actually has a couple of good car Mayhem
moments car fights that
I mean that's the Twisted Metal flavor
right there with bad CGI absolutely but
complete with cheesy 90s action car
Mayhem it's 10 30 minute episodes so
what it means is if you're having a
party of some sort it's going to be a
few hours dude put Twisted Metal on in
the backgrounds
and just let the good times roll it's
it's a perfect series for that perfectly
encapsulates the more positive side of
my good time if you're drunk writing
when I'm not being like a curmudgeonous
[__] like yeah you need to get [__]
face have yourself a night of some 90s
action cheese made in 2023 with some
jokes that fall flat some fun Carnation
a show that's endearing in its own way I
will say this is life spoilers it's just
one voice in one scene you hear Calypso
on an intercom I was not feeling that it
just didn't didn't sound like Calypso to
me it didn't feel like Calypso to me
going forward for season two I hope
Calypso does feel like Calypso also
there's no Mr Grim in here
the next season now
man Mr Grim's the best I love me my
glass cannons from Twisted Metal One on
PS1 I was like I like the guy on the
bike and then his ending was just the
best ending in the game all right so
Twisted Metal season one have you seen
it what did you think about it what's
your favorite Twisted Metal game you can
rank them if you're going nuts but just
favorite for me the ones I listed
earlier in the video for sure I think
Twisted Metal on PS3 is Peak Twisted
Metal I would love to see a PS5 Twisted
Metal but I gotta say the end credits to
Twisted Metal black with painted black
I watched that [__] on repeat but
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
foreign